mais là va dire c'est par un sujet qui
nous touche vous et nous de plus près
que nous allons ouvrir ce soir notre
émission depuis trois jours en effet les
troupes américaines ont quitté le sol du
cambodge de cette guerre qui aura duré
60 jours des hommes et des femmes qu'on
appelle les correspondants de guerre
auront essayé pendant deux mois dans nos
journaux ici mais aussi dans tous les
journaux du monde de vous donner une
image aussi fidèle aussi exact que
possible et pour accomplir cette tâche
23 d'entre eux sont morts ou ont disparu
vingt-trois hommes et femmes qui
n'appartenait à aucun des deux camps
mais à cette grande armée de
l'information qui n'est là que pour
votre service et bien un hommage à leur
métier et à ce qu'ils sont nous allons
vous présenter pour commencer à travers
le portrait de l'un d'entre eux le
portrait collectif de ses correspondants
de guerre
je m'appelle bernard une main je suis
les journalistes depuis 23 ans j'ai
maintenant 48 ans
j'ai commencé ma carrière à la radio
française et puis de là se passait le
vbc de la souvenu à l' agence
france-presse
actuellement je suis essentiellement
transporteur fait en ce moment je
finissais au cambodge comme envoyé
spécial pour couvrir cette guerre
[Musique]
tom pen n'est pas laïque ont ici c'est
un peu la guerre qui n'en a pas l'air la
guerre improvisé chaque correspondant
doit profiter au maximum des
informations de ses confrères l'esprit
est constamment en alerte
georges steve ashton est un reporter de
la grande compagnie américaine de
télévision cbs
geri müller son ami travaille pour la
même maison regardez bien ces deux
hommes mila et stylos ce temps nul
caméra ne les filmera plus jamais vivant
leur disparition et celle d'autres
confrères on se traduire par 3 journée
dramatique dans ce reportage
conscient du danger ils le sont hier
c'est leur équipe y réchapper par une
chance extraordinaire d'une embuscade
sur la route de tak et un aujourd'hui
d'autres camarades raconte comment leur
embarcation a été mitraillé sur le
mékong il semble que les viets soit
nulle part et partout
leur réaction pas reste imprévisible
l'armée khmère est dépassé
week end
bernard houlmann demain vous sortez
puisque vous avez une seconde penser aux
risques que vous prenez
vous l'avez soupeser série super sport
se posent pas de risques c'est vrai
quand vous faites un voyage en voiture
on vous dit pas toutes les deux minutes
de jeu et ne rentrait d'un platane enfin
oui c'est certain ça existe
est ce que ça vous à cabourg ce que ça
vous excite plutôt sedan j'ai
préféré travailler sans risque
je ne cherche pas là j'avais dit fier
votre attitude cet égard vous qui avez
été surtout les grands coups
de gueule
pas profondément
profondément que je m'étais fixé au 4
août
wilson et les garçons équipe travaille
pour une chaîne de télévision américaine
la nbc aujourd'hui nous les rencontrons
en opération après demain leurs noms
figureront sur la liste des disparus
[Musique]
j'ai fait les américains viennent
jusqu'ici avec leur date est la limite
quelle est la situation ici ici à agnac
loup mouysset le cette fois ces grands
points de passage sur la route dans se
montre sion et
cliff la peine puisque au delà au delà
on vend des centres prévenu canine et
say no aujourd'hui
le problème c'est d'arriver jusqu'à
prévenu qu'après 20 ans qu hier soir
encore les les viennent sur franche et
sinon dans la ville du moins aux
alentours immédiats alors se voir avec
se trouve au nord est la route et coupé
les ponts sont coupés alors on va
essayer d'y aller par hélicoptère s'est
retrouvée lundi comme terre subit une
forte
l'armée du général lon nol ne possède
pas d'hélicoptère et transport aérien
qui sont appelés petits bien pour les
correspondants basés à saigon reste donc
inexistant lorsqu'on part de phnom penh
aujourd'hui c'est l'exception parce que
les sud vietnamiens sont là
et quelques cadavres
[Musique]
le mari
du
paquebot
allons y
et
dans l'helmand
entre mâles sont à rendre à 1500 et 2000
et ils ont fortement
avec canon 105
annonçant 5 capes tienne
tapia
ils nous ont bombardés de jour et de
nuit 1
ils nous ont attaqué ma terre sautées
quoi leur côté et s'ils sont nombreux
et sont repliés pas
l'important définitive que les viets
soit à 5 x 10 km ce qui compte c'est que
la ville est tenue pour le moment par
les sud vietnamien venus en renfort
aujourd'hui je vous force à faire
réfléchir à chaud pose des questions
mais je ne vous en faisait
je m'oppose oui je me pose de temps en
temps mais je vous dis papa pendant je
travaille mais détail qui m'a frappé
tout à l'heure vous avez sorti une
petite cour de whiskies et bu un coup
oui parce que je suis que la vue des
cadavres et l'odeur des cadavres
on s'habitue pas
bon on y va
[Musique]
j'ai fait
profitons d'un transport de munitions
pour quitter prévenu quelques heures
plus tard la ville tombera de nouveau
aux mains des viets
en rentrant d'opérations avant même de
se rafraîchir un correspondant doit
écrire son papier le porter à la poste
hélas parfois négocier son texte avec la
censure à la centrale des téléscripteurs
à quelques kilomètres de là on continue
à se battre
l hôtel royal c'est évidemment les sens
que notre activité est ici eh oui tout
ce passe un petit feu autour de la
piscine c'est ici qu'on voit revenir les
hanter sa part qui sera couronné
habitons et puis cet effet de bourse le
bourse aux nouvelles nous avons vus
ensemble un certain nombre d'horaires
vous avez écrit les papilles là dessus
de l'expédier ça paris j'ai l'impression
que quelque chose change nous avons une
efficacité qui est qui est très limité
je suis dans certains cas c'est certain
que je crois moi peut-être dans le cas
du biafra peut-être ici quand on a quand
on a attiré l'attention de l'opinion un
peu partout sur le sort des vietnamiens
ici sur certaines
exactions dont ils étaient victimes
ça a peut être freiné et peut-être au
fond n'en sais rien disons que ça quand
même peut-être un petit peu limité dans
certains cas me passait ça va pas très
loin la formation à votre disposition
est ce que cela suppose chez vous
bernard houlmann un engagement politique
non je crois je dirais
à phnom penh la journée d'un
correspondant de guerre commence par le
rituel briefing du haut commandement
militaire cette journée là sera la
première d'une série dramatique
[Musique]
détruits quelle serait la situation aux
environs de taquets puisqu'il ya des
quelques journalistes correspondants
disparu vous savez quelque chose
derrière méthodes
innovatrices paris hier
[Musique]
avec les chauffeurs référence personnes
qui en ont
j'ai pas de nouvelles a donc amené je
vais me lancer y est je dirais à utah
qui
travaillent qui contre attaque entre
l'os et nos forces aof rhodia vous avez
dans le communiqué du haut commandement
nous avons déjà réinstallé
la rumeur se confirme c'est grave huit
journalistes et opérateurs ainsi que
trois cambodgiens qui les accompagnent
ne sont pas rentrés les coûts sont
inhalées
à pouvoir le chantier qui étaient
jusqu'à
présent rien du tout
oui
bernard ce sont des journalistes des
photographes des caméras belge équipe de
télévision
la route de takéo midi nous voici au
dernier poste clair que les camarades
ont franchi avant le drame de kilomètres
plus loin au village de rhinebeck ils
sont tombés en embuscade soldats ont
entendu une explosion des villageois
auraient vu une jeep calcinés et deux
voitures abandonnées
ils ne sont pas tellement à l'aise parce
que tous les côtés il ya un peu la
jungle 5 km le premier poste et on peut
facilement être couplé ou les déchirent
lui il a quel age
ii soit 17 ans des civic ont 18 ans
vous avez voir le viet congs passé là
bas nous il y a il est con
icilaba la pagode et si oui est-ce que
vous avez des moyens de vous communiquer
est ce qu'on pouvait parler
radio avec peine non non non non
je n'ai pas de radio
est ici plusieurs bataillons de viet
congs plus jeune pâtissier qu'on voit là
et ici s'il n'y a pas de partie cette
compagnie de deux compagnies windows et
paniers de compagnie
embarrassé
voilà
impossible donc d'avancer nous risquons
tout gaiement l'encerclement
[Musique]
attention
6 heures du matin c'est cool tu sais que
l'on a devant nous soyez attention oui
le biais de comptes et à part de ce
matin encore maintenant
merci au revoir
et
journaliste
merci
le deuxième jour les renforts khmer sont
toujours insuffisants on ne peut pas
percer jusqu'à l'épave de la jeep capter
oui 4 oui
d'emplois celui qui est allé voir les
voitures des journalistes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la charité jusqu'aux voitures en plus
convoité ce mot allah le pont a miné le
flou pour aminé seulement à gauche à
gauche des six mètres mais ce matin j'ai
envoyé une
camionnette un jour incomplet mais on ne
peut pas on peut pas se douter de lui
alors il y en a beaucoup mais yann
beaucoup de blessés chez nous là
vraiment on a attaqué depuis le 5 heures
du matin jusqu'à midi même
les voitures sont tachées de sang 1 et
du sang dans les voitures non je
fouillais n'y pas de sens seulement
collage est présente à dire que par
l'agent de renseignement que il est
attaqué par la machine catalane a
également les quatre les quatre hommes
de danse on
les avait vus montabert la
d'enseignement l'a
vu arriver j'ai alors est-il c'étaient
des gens bien ou des années jamais kg 4
tous les quatre dans mon cas
tous les quatre étaient légales il a vu
des papiers a reçu des coups de quelque
chose non seulement que nos emplois dont
presque tous les endroits dans nos
agents de renseignement voilà ça faisait
comme ça il faut que tu nous donnes
automatiquement chaque journée des
annonces et m'ouvre les villageois
quatre de ces billets
et j conques sont là toujours nous
venons il ya il a bien molli sont bien
installés
rêvé d'être un libéral comme ça il ya
toujours des métiers de 30 des marchés
de 80 de taux de change les recalés tout
ça il fallait attendre
les toiles de la route il ya les maisons
isolées alors ce monsieur là ils ont
sauté dessus alors ça c'est bien beau
temps
à votre nom c'est le
cas
du président tandja
veut dire
sachant toujours
les éléments cui recentrage pas quelle
distance une saillie ses positions ils
sont encerclés et il ya personne qui
arrive venant du revenant de l'arrière
entre les paillettes à l'opération en
cours ça peut lui ajouter journée où je
vois l'intérêt bastille simon
l'échec l'incertitude qui plane sur le
sort des camarades disparus n'arrête pas
l'implacable loi du métier il faut
rentrer pour envoyer le papier
c'est peut-être bon tuyau de cet épicier
qu'on avait là
que quelques précisions je n'avais pas
par exemple le fait que
qui est des officiers quinté fox qui
était dans les forces spéciales
américaines
[Musique]
vietnam tous les hôpitaux
et qu'ils ont dû maintenant en quarts et
des batailles régulier normes et mère
d'un fait nouveau un pouvoir de par
sa voix papier ça bon ça vaut pas un
papier mais s'avoue
impressionné
[Musique]
ce matin tout le monde est venu au
briefing le commandement militaire a
annoncé l' assaut final prennent acte
doit être repris les gars de la nbc et
de les cibler ce sont les premiers à
pied d'oeuvre ce sont leurs proches amis
qui ont disparu qui se croiraient ici en
première ligne tout est désert
cette guerre improvisé éparpillés
épisodique et traître pour les
correspondants le risque devient
incalculable bilan à ce jour 23 disparus
cette jeune femme n'a manqué aucune
expédition c'est une journaliste
brésilienne elle avance ici en compagnie
de trois collègues britanniques
[Musique]
attention les gars
[Applaudissements]
rina qu ils n ont plus de soixante dix
heures que nous voulions atteindre ce
point
fowler images tournées les collègues
américains fouilles l'épave calcinée de
la jeep dans l'espoir de découvrir
quelques singles
non
[Musique]
macabre de voir d'amitié
l'identification des cadavres dans une
atmosphère torride est pestilentielle ça
est ce vraiment georges ou peut-être
jerry
commandant des dizaines de fosses qu'on
a rouverte discerner parmi ces corps en
décomposition les restes de nos
confrères parmi ceux des soldats
cela portait des lunettes le journaliste
oui la détente et à
son éditeur
c'est là que sont morts nos deux
collègues de la nbc très probablement on
croit avoir trouvé une paire de lunettes
sa tête est celle de justin lofton
journalistes geri müller était pour moi
dans cette logique aussi elle a pris un
coup de bazooka ils sont entrés dans
ceni viêt sans s'en douter je pense que
leur corps a dû être déchiquetés
quant aux autres journalistes qui ne
sont peut-être pas mort bien nous
pensons qu'ils ont été retenus
prisonniers dans ce village y est
quelques heures quelques jours et puis
maintenant ils ont disparu c'est là que
nous espérions trouver les dernières
traces de leur passage nous n'avons rien
trouvé nous ne savons plus rien eu comme
de tous les autres ils ont disparu à
nantes eux
le fatiguer bernard oui je suis fatigué
tu passes en séries quand tu as combien
de temps
quel gâchis
à l'avant
moi je vais essayer de partir sur la
route qu'à voir ce qui se passe
pas dormir un peu
[Musique]